is there a way you could share like take
five minutes to share with any
filmmakers that have never solved the
iPhone you want to shoot a feature home
sure there are a few things I'd
recommend first off every film is
different so I sometimes don't like
giving advice because if I do I'm
talking about one particular aesthetic
you know what I mean so but but if there
are a few things that I would suggest
filmmakers do if they're using on the
eyelids video using the iPhone one of
them is get a stabilizer you try to
handhold an iPhone it really does look
terrible in my eyes you may want to go
for that look but because the lens is so
tiny no matter how stable you think you
might be the human hand shakes and that
translates pretty poorly when it gets
onto the big screen there's a wobbly
sort of this is very unattractive
shakiness that's that can be fixed if
you have a stabilizer so we used a
smoothie which is that's what it's
called it's a smoothie by Steadicam and
tiffin and it's really just a little
grip it's about an eight inch grip and
it's a Steadicam for an iPhone so that
and then also sound you know sounds very
important on any production I get a lot
of Twitter messages and Facebook
messages asking me how I record it on
the iPhone when I say I didn't record
from the iPhone week we recorded
professionally separately and we sunk in
post
you know ayran Strauss had a full who
was our sound recordist wonderful very
talented artist he he basically was able
to he recorded everything the way you
would normally record on any feature
film with his digital unit and
is hot very high quality mics both you
know both shotgun mics and lavaliers and
then we sunk in post and that's very
important because you know an audience
will they can accept anything visually
because that is sort of like this
aesthetic that you're presenting to the
audience but with the sound isn't there
the sound isn't crisp and easy to hear
and understand it's it's a no-go so
spend money on on your sound and do it
properly and those are the two things
that I would say will get you
technically there and then just in terms
of just generally approaching iPhone
filmmaking I would say we're at such an
early stage of using you know almost
like devices that aren't cameras to make
films that you can do whatever you want
that's the thing that's we just
experimented and we just said what
benefits are to be found here and let's
just try different things you know you
can get this little device into us into
nooks and crannies that you wouldn't be
able to get you know a big camera into
you can you can they're so lightweight
you can move them easily you can throw
them on a drone and and get your nice
aerial shots you can do whatever you
want we just you know we we just started
experimenting there during production
and in tangerine is what resulted but
I'm sure you know a filmmaker out there
who you know just wants it to to come up
with their own aesthetic it's very easy
to because it's it's a bit it's it's
quite this thing is actually look at it
I'm just throwing it around right now
I'm not you can't do that with a
35-millimeter camera that's the big
difference
you